hi there I'm Marcus founder of the
fluent me and Google AI champion
we offer AI powered pronunciation
feedback to Second Language speakers and
gen AIS will allow us to offer this
feedback differently much more
interactive and based on user-driven
chats this also means a different
approach to content on learning
platforms which will be AI generated in
real time and by request of users
we're excited about combining generative
ai's audio video images text they can
all be used together to to build
simulations that Learners can experience
rather than imagine
the best part about these learning
experiences is that they will be
available to millions of users worldwide
who do not even have access to education
today